hey youtubers is charlie and there are
only two more days until doctor who
comes back so this video is going to be
a master guide for all the episodes with
synopsis from Steven Moffat that's right
straight from the horse's mouth he
basically said a little bit about each
episode this series and everybody cheer
because the BBC is bringing back doctor
who confidential as a web series it's
going to be called Doctor Who extra
there'll be 10 minute videos that will
play after each episode of Doctor Who
but it is exclusive to the UK I player
they haven't made any official
announcement as to whether or not
they're going to make these available to
international people like people in the
US and people in other countries the
first episode is going to be in the
iPlayer this Saturday the 23rd after
episode 1 runs from 750 p.m. gmt 2 9-10
so you'll be able to watch that first
extra episode at nine ten that's UK time
remember BBC america and the other
networks that run doctor who you know
depending on where you live haven't
announced if they're doing any kind of
behind the scenes episodes but BBC
America is doing an after show after
they run Doctor Who this weekend even if
you're not able to watch those extra
little webisodes I'll still include info
from them in my videos week to week
which reminds me new giveaway starts
right now so all you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber and leave a comment
on this video remember it's going to be
a new giveaway each week this series so
here's the master episode schedule with
official synopsis from Steven Moffat
these are just the regular episodes it
doesn't include information on the
Christmas special so I'm just going to
run these as a montage
you
some of the dates for those later
episodes are subject to change but if
you'll notice the big difference between
the Matt Smith era episodes and these
are that there's no mid-season break and
the stories are less serialized that
just means that it's going to be easier
for new who viens to keep up with the
story even if they miss episodes it just
as a reminder on the giveaway though
weekly giveaways will start whenever I
post each episode review Saturday nights
all you have to do to enter those is be
a subscriber and leave a comment on the
videos i'll be posting weekly bonus
videos before episodes air and then the
reviews will post after episodes there
and then on sundays i'll do the Q&A
videos where all announced the winner
from the giveaways my next bonus video
is going to be my favorite catchphrases
i'll post that tomorrow this saturday i
will post my review of episode 1 a
little bit earlier than normal but i
will have spoiler warnings i'm probably
gonna live-tweet the episode but not in
a spoilery way my twitter handle is
awesome emergency i know it's a little
bit weird but my facebook is still like
facebook / emergency awesome so feel
free to follow me there so right now
click here to find out which episodes I
think you should watch before watching
series 8 and click here to find out
which classic episodes I think you
should check out thank you so much for
watching I'll see you guys tonight high
fives
you